mais là on est plus dans la prudence
sanitaire là on et j'allais dire
l'expression mais je crois qu'il faut
déjà dit on est dans la punition
j'ai cru que j'avais mal
en dut d'abord donc j'ai vérifié après
sur internet maintenant j'avais bien
entendu je me suis dit parle comme si
c'était il ya quinze jours c'était une
valve d'une mesure valable ya quinze
jours ça éventuellement mais au jour
d'aujourd'hui et incompréhensibles pour
nous pour toute taille d'église dont la
cathédrale de 1000 personnes ou dans une
église de village de 200 personnes
on est limité à 30 personnes en fait il
pour la jauge qu'ils ont défini pour les
sépultures et les temps à tout pour tout
aille d'aegis tout type de célébration
et surtout c'est complètement
incompréhensible pour noël je pense
qu'il ait jamais les dans une église un
soir de noël
c'est incompréhensible alors qu'est-ce
qui aura le plus fait le minimum qu'on
puisse de monter c'est qu' un changement
au 20 décembre que ça change pour noël
parce que quelque chose qui n'est pas
réalisable ça peut être acceptée par les
français
et ça sera pas acceptable et cela ne
sera pas accepté donc c'est irréalisable
je suis dans l'incompréhension totale
sur ce chiffre là ce que les évêques
avaient demandé clairement ce n'était
pas une jauge c'était un pourcentage par
rapport aux églises des mètres carrés
par rapport à la taille de l'église
voilà et puis la deuxième chose c'est
vraiment nous respectueux pour les
croyants quelle que soit leur religion
ou quelles que soient leurs croyances le
jour où un exemple d'un fois qu'ils
arrêtent il a rencontré les responsables
des différents cultes il leur a demandé
les des protocoles sauf qu'on lui avait
déjà envoyé les protocoles du manque
quelque chose qu'il avait déjà hélas à
reis particules enfin on est dans
l'incompréhension totale et je leur dis
quelque chose qui n'est pas
compréhensible pourra pas être admis et
donc ce sera contre-productif ce sera
contre productif
complètement
d'abord c'est le signe d'une grande
méconnaissance de la réalité de des
croyants dans notre pays c'est d'assumer
une grande méconnaissance en gros les
gens qui nous gouvernent sont jamais
allés à une messe dans une église vous
ne sont jamais allés à une messe de noël
donc c'est us et une inculture aussi
parce que la messe de noël ce sont eux
qui sont culture dans notre pays donc
c'est une inculture et puis je crois que
c'est aussi un manque de respect pour
les croyants ce n'est pas prendre en
compte l'importance alors on peut nous
faire des beaux discours sur
l'accompagnement des personnes ce qu'il
nous a fait ce soir
mais excusez moi le premier
accompagnement des caisses des personnes
c'est aussi un accompagnement spirituel
en gros vous pourrez aller à 2000
personnes dans un centre commercial ça
vous posera aucun problème puisque là il
n'y a pas de jauge de personnes pour
consommer à les y consommer mais on
n'ira pas plus loin
dont j'ai fait partie des évêques qui
ont fait ce recours au conseil d'état
et là je crois que ça va être un peu
nécessaire de retourner au conseil
d'état donc on va hanter les deux choses
c'est à dire d'une part retourner à la
négociation sans beaucoup d'espoir mais
on va aussi retourner devant le conseil
d'état
et puis le troisième aspect c'est je le
vois bien sûr mon diocèse qui est un
diocèse rural où les chrétiens sont
mobilisés alors il me téléphoner qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire et ce qu'il faut
manifester ou pas donc je leur disais
patienter pour l'instant patienter on
espère pour l'instant ça des mesures de
prudence sanitaire mais là on est au
delà des mesures de prudence sanitaire
je ne vois pas comment je pourrais dire
aux chrétiens et ben non rester
tranquillement chez vous ou fera une
sélection d'un sur je ne sais pas
combien pour les allées mais c'est
réalisable
je
me poser des questions je leur ai plutôt
demander à ceux qui m'avaient contacté
pour l'instant c'est des mesures de
prudence sanitaire
soyons raisonnables et donc je vais
réfléchir sur ce que je vais faire mais
je pense que ma position a évolué